[Música]
eu queria fazer um convite a todos vocês
vou imaginar um dia abrir os nossos
jornais assim logo que chego em casa
quando a gente vai comprar na banca ea
gente olha essa manchete aqui brasil
acelera crescimento com forte redução
das desigualdades
imagina só gente contra isso mostra a
manchete é queda vertiginosa dos índices
de violência coloca o brasil entre os
países mais seguros do mundo
jinan colocava mais uma terceira a gente
conseguia imaginar o brasil lidera a
produção científica de ponta e muda sua
matriz econômica da china
eu acho que esse é realmente o sonho de
todos nós e vão a gente quer um dia
chegar nessas manchetes um dia chegar
com essa alegria de abrir os jornais
encontrar essas manchetes estampadas nos
jornais
agora tem uma manchete que a gente
precisa atingir que a gente precisa
alcançar que a gente precisa ter
antes de chegar nessas três aqui que é
uma chatice que explica o porquê que o
brasil demora tanto para atingir esses
outros resultados ea manchete que a
gente precisa batalhar muito para
conseguir chegar nela é essa aqui
o brasil é o país que mais cresce no
pisa na última década e encosta na elite
da educação mundial
essa é a manchete que a gente precisa
conquistar para que todas as outras
também sejam alcançadas
essa grande batalha acho que de muita
gente que está aqui muita gente que
assiste a esse vídeo o que a gente
precisa batalhar e fazer com que as
pessoas sejam o grande foco das nossas
políticas públicas das nossas lutas
todas as nossas batalhas os nossos
trabalhos
o brasil nunca vai conseguir chegar no
patamar de desenvolvimento social e
econômico é o que a gente quer
se a gente não garantir educação de
qualidade para todos
o ponto que está atrás
wando o desenvolvimento do brasil é
justamente uma baixíssima qualidade da
nossa educação e da educação pública
o que a gente precisa é de prioridade
nas pessoas
eu acho que é é fácil pelo menos é
intuitivo a gente entender que por trás
de cada política econômica de cada
política de segurança pública de cada
atendimento médico de cada é a de cada
empresa que aberta de cada esforço nosso
nos nossos projetos quando a gente olha
para os nossos pequenos e grandes
sucessos como que a gente explica esses
sucessos são sempre as pessoas são
sempre as pessoas que o brasil precisa
encarar o fato que a crise de
aprendizagem que a gente vive hoje o
país tem dificultado ou têm travado esse
desenvolvimento então essa é a primeira
idéia que eu gostaria de ser espalhada
disseminada pelo país
a gente precisa colocar a educação como
eixo central do nosso projeto de país
não existe a menor possibilidade do
brasil crescer se desenvolver e
distribuir renda e ter mais
oportunidades pra todos viver num país
mais seguro se a gente não resolverá
educação pública ea educação pública que
não é só a nossa dos nossos filhos da
nossa comunidade é educação pública de
todos
então esse é o grande desafio do país
que da mesma forma que o brasil se
tornou os brasileiros se tornaram
intolerante em relação à inflação a
corrupção falta de emprego porque a
gente aceita tão facilmente uma baixa
qualidade da educação pública aqui no
país
eu vou dizer sim quando quando e se esse
sino bateu na minha cabeça quando eu
realmente passei a olhar para a educação
pública porque eu olhava pra isso eu
também estava na minha bolha achando que
bastava eu lutar pela minha própria
educação lutar para ter um bom emprego e
que as coisas vão se resolver e eu não
tinha muita idéia que a educação dos
outros me afetava tanto aconteceu há
muitos anos
já a e foi quando eu mudei de carreira
na verdade foi o clique que me bateu eu
saí do meu super emprego que eu tinha
pra entrar no terceiro setor
eu eu era professora de matemática de
fazer reforço na periferia de são paulo
no jardim varginha um lugar muito pobre
aqui dado da zona sul de são paulo e eu
ajudava alunos que vinham com
dificuldade em matemática e eu todo
sábado de manhã ela fazendo reforço
escolar para as crianças e elas vêm com
muita dificuldade
a defasagem de aprendizagem que vinham
de outros anos muita muita dificuldade
mesmo mas aí o menino que eu não eu não
sei o nome dele
ele passou na minha vida ficou aqui até
hoje mas eu não sei nem o nome dele eu
vou chamar de pedro só para facilitar o
pedro virou pra mim falou o seguinte tia
a educação não é pra mim eu não nasci
pra estudar
educação não é pra mim não sabe e ele
saiu
ele foi embora ele acreditou que a
educação não era pra ele ele acreditou o
que muitos de nós de uma forma
consciente ou não a gente aceita e acaba
acreditando que a educação de qualidade
para uns e tem outros que tudo bem tem
outros que não vão ter educação de
qualidade e essa é a realidade do brasil
hoje
dos cem alunos que entram no ensino
fundamental um ano no primeiro ano
só 64 concluem o ensino médio até os 19
anos de idade
olha a invasão olha quantos jovens está
perdendo no caminho e dos que conclui
só nove de cada 100 aprendem o mínimo
adequado em matemática
então olha o sistema de exclusão que a
gente está criando no brasil e agora dá
pra entender porque a gente nunca vai
conseguir chegar àquelas manchetes que
eu mostrei aqui pra vocês se a gente não
destravava e passar a investir realmente
nas pessoas é isso que vai fazer a
diferença
que vai fazer a diferença são sempre as
pessoas ea gente precisa colocar então a
educação nesse eixo central do nosso
projeto de país para qualquer vantagem
que a gente vive hoje porque outras
gerações não fizeram essa tarefa no
colocar a educação no centro não
resolveram essa questão porque a gente
não tá num outro patamar porque a gente
tem uma vantagem agora e as vantagens
também nos trazem mais responsabilidades
qualquer vantagem que a gente tem agora
porque eu tenho absoluta convicção que a
gente tem toda a possibilidade de fazer
a revolução na educação hoje no país
até pouco tempo atrás poucas décadas
atrás a gente não tinha muita clareza de
quais eram as políticas os caminhos as
estratégias para a gente chegar e bons
resultados de aprendizagem
a gente tinha uma série de experiências
experimentos no painel e fora daqui do
país em outros países mas a gente não
tinha quantidade de evidências que a
gente tem hoje
hoje a gente tem as evidências para sair
desse patamar baixíssimo de qualidade da
educação e colocar o brasil em outro
patamar de aprendizagem garantindo assim
a aprendizagem dos seus alunos e
destravando o desenvolvimento social e
econômico do nosso país
essas evidências são algumas não são
muitas por isso que o lado todos pela
educação a gente sempre fica muito
incomodados quando governos vão pra
outros caminhos que não aqueles que a
gente tem as evidências porque isso é
perda de dinheiro de recursos de tempo
de foco de governo e essas grandes
estratégias que a gente estudou que a
gente organizou um grande plano que se
chama educação já que é um plano
estratégico para a gente até 2030 sub 50
pontos no pisa
o que esse plano mostra-se plano mostra
vocês vão ver
não tem nada que não seja muito razoável
e que vocês digam não de fato a gente
tem que fazer isso a gente tem que fazer
isso mas não está fazendo a primeira
infância o desenvolvimento social
cognitivo emocional físico ele é em
grande medida o formado
os três primeiros anos as crianças ea
gente não tem uma política nacional
potente para garantir esse
desenvolvimento principalmente das
crianças mais pobres que têm menos
oportunidades de aprendizagem fora de
casa ou dentro de casa em tempo integral
você sabe a gente chama aqui no brasil
de escola de tempo regular de tempo
integral no resto do mundo nos países
que estão nos primeiros lugares do pisa
não existe tempo regular e tempo
integral nas escolas são de sete horas
não existe essa diferença aqui no brasil
a gente se agrega e aqueles alunos que
dão sorte vou estudar em escolas de
tempo integral e tem aqueles alunos que
não têm acesso a tempo integral
a gente tem que implementar a base
nacional como curricular
a gente tem que mudar o nosso sistema de
financiamento para que ele seja mais
redistributivo
a gente precisa melhorar a governança da
nossa educação ea gestão no ministério
da educação nas secretarias e
principalmente nas escolas
vocês sabiam que mais da metade mais de
70% dos municípios brasileiros escolhem
os seus diretores de escolas por
indicação política
então como é que a gente vai ter uma
escola bem digerida uma escola com as
condições de trabalho dos professores
com essa situação de ainda indicação
política a gente precisa mudar isso
agora tem um fator é o fator
interessante porque da mesma forma que
eu disse no começo aqui da minha fala
que a gente não investir nas pessoas e
por isso a gente vem errando no nosso
país ea gente não tem conseguido os
resultados que a gente precisa dentro
das políticas educacionais qual é o
nosso maior erro
o nosso maior erro é que a gente também
não investe nas pessoas que fazem
educação e quem faz a educação no brasil
o professor que é o principal
profissional desse país
o professor é o principal fator de
qualidade é aquele que garante a
qualidade a aprendizagem ou não a
aprendizagem dos nossos alunos o
professor
ele é o maior determinante
essa qualidade da educação ea educação é
o maior determinante do sucesso do nosso
país e portanto das nossas vidas então o
a gente coloca na agenda do nosso país e
na nossa agenda também de valorização do
professor que o professor o principal
profissional do país
ou estamos aqui condenados ao fracasso
civilizatório porque esse é um
imperativo ético de todos nós
o imperativo estratégico de nação das
nossas vidas também valorizar o
professor e melhorar a atratividade para
a carreira
melhorar a formação inicial desses
professores melhorar a formação em
serviço as condições de trabalho ea
carreira de professor
adivinhem a gente faz o oposto disso
aqui no país
o professor e não é valorizado e não
existe nenhum tipo de apoio a esses
professores para eles fazerem esse
trabalho que é tão importante para todos
nós isso não é só responsabilidade da
gestão pública a gente precisa cobrar
essa gestão pública para poder tratar
melhor o professor agora é valorizar
para valorizar não é isso também
hoje qualquer situação que a gente tem a
gente está muito pouco para o professor
espera muito pouco resultado dele também
é como se a gente tivesse desistido
o que a gente precisa mudar é porque a
gente vê e verifica nos países que
tenham resultados no pisa que essa prova
que avalia alunos jovens de 15 anos no
mundo inteiro aprendizagem deles o que
que a gente verifica nesses países que
estão no topo do ranking do pisa lá
professor é valorizado bem formado e
resultados cobrados por que é tão
importante para todos nós que a gente
espera muito resultado desse professor
então é a gente vai inverter
completamente passou que está hoje
hoje a gente tem um patamar baixo de
apoio espera nada e deixa rolar até
porque é muita gente pensa que olha o
meu filho eu a gente está se virando a
gente consegue uma educação de qualidade
e muitas vezes não se dá conta que a
educação do outro que a educação da
criança e do jovem que a gente nunca vai
ver na
vida que é a mais importante pra gente
porque é essa educação para todos é a
educação dos 91 por cento dos alunos que
concluem o ensino médio que não tem
aprendizagem mínimo adequado em
matemática
é essa a educação que me importa é essa
a educação que deveria importar todos
nós e aí vem a terceira ideia que eu
gostaria aqui de espalhar nesse ted a
primeira educação como prioridade
nacional segunda ideia professor
principal profissional do país
a terceira ideia é a ideia poderosa que
pode fazer a gente sair desse lugar
desse lugar de complacência desse lugar
de tudo bem a gente tem outras coisas
pra fazer o brasil tem uma série de
problemas
educação é super importante mas gente
não é urgente é urgente sim a gente já
teve ondas no país de intolerância a uma
série de outras situações que forçaram a
gestão pública os governantes a
trabalharem naquela direção
nós da sociedade nós não demandamos não
colocamos pressão na gestão pública nos
governantes daqueles que a gente volta
pra melhorar a qualidade do da educação
e como que a gente pode fazer isso todos
pela educação de todos é quando a gente
inaugurar um outro momento de entender
que a fraternidade a solidariedade que
eu acredito que todos nós brasileiros
temos ela é um ponto fundamental do
nosso povo das civilizações que são
prósperas daquelas dos grupos que têm
uma longevidade uma força ao longo do
tempo que são as religiões
aquilo que nos une você sabia que
solidariedade vem de sólido aquilo que
não só na sólidos como sociedade é a
solidariedade que a gente pode colocar
em prática para ajudar a criança eo
jovem que a gente não conhece é passar a
batalhar e cobrar resultados dos
governos começaram a se envolver começar
a subir o nosso tom de indignação
começar a deixar de ser completa
sente em relação a essa situação que
está travando a nossa vida a vida do
país
a vida das pessoas que mais precisam da
nossa ajuda essa ideia de solidariedade
de fraternidade de cuidado de cuidar do
outro de cuidar do outro que eu não
conheço é a ideia mais poderosa e que
pode ser o ponto de contato o ponto de
apoio para o brasil fazer a revolução na
educação que é a revolução pelo
investimento nas pessoas que a gente não
pode mais tolerar que nenhuma criança
como pedro acredite que educação não é
pra ele
da mesma forma que a gente não pode mais
ter aqui no brasil e acreditar que a
educação não é pra gente
então todos pela educação de todos muito
obrigado
[Aplausos]